what's up reject nation i know we're a
few days late to
jake paul versus nate robinson full
fight i don't
really follow these guys and i don't
follow these like celebrity boxing
matches
but i had enough people message me like
hey dude you gotta react to this this is
the link this is the link and i'm like
i'll just say full fight but they're
five minutes long
yeah now like i i know the i know the
winner
but i didn't know the details all right
sure this might be fun to check out yeah
i want to see
jake paul uh demonstrate his prowess oh
yeah
let's see what's in store because that's
how i heard that if it's super
short that sounds funny let's watch it
media superstar we got a hip-hop icon
hey man let's get cracking man
let's get cracking so the professional
debut of
nate robinson and stoop i know you're an
uber sports fan
is this the actual full fight this is
crazy
we got
[Laughter]
speed speed
um
look like they grappling out there
his first fight though so you know he's
live
you're in this commentary and knowing
who wins
and even received advice from the one
and only floyd mayweather how do you
like him so
far i like him i just wanted to take his
time to be a little bit more patient and
wait for it instead of trying to bring
it
you're familiar with the sport right
oh
he was
robinson looks like he's been rattled
he's gonna get a background in like pro
athletics
wow again it's not pretty
it's a fight
wow
oh man no he he should just uh
this is the video they had to upload it
this way in order to get it on youtube
when i was in the ring i was talking to
swing and bring it
[Laughter]
snoop dogg is my favorite part of this
sad for the boys
letting him showcase that well he's
doing the right things but like you said
he's gonna like take his time oh there
we go
now he's taking his time he's forced you
now
and he gotta switch it up because he's
probably a professional fighter you
can't do the same moves every time
i'm comfortable
oh
at the time
oh
just felt like a ton of bricks there
yeah
oh that that was hard to watch it away
it was like the least bloody violent
boxing match i've seen it yet somehow i
was just so uncomfortable watching it
was more uncomfortable you know what i
think i think
knowing what i heard was that nate lost
and he got knocked out
and i didn't realize how short the fight
was until people were sending me links
and then i was like looking up
highlights i'm like why are the
highlights only 10 seconds
and now you can exactly see why there's
almost
nothing actually like i don't know much
about the sport of boxing and so when i
see good boxing i am able to pick up a
little bit on like
here's where some of the technical side
might come into play sure this did not
do that at all for me
i know we upset real boxing fans for
whenever we said hugging it's
clinching sorry it's clinching okay
if they had gotten one punch out i might
have started using it
my subconscious reaction to there and i
think hugging and i don't think of the
technical term okay yeah i mean in the
beginning it was a lot of that and
and even the ref who was like what the
hell's going on guys one moment
what are we doing what are we doing this
is round one
and just wanted to kind of play as i
don't know it was a weird
mixture of like complete offense i'm
just like i'm just gonna dive at you
with punches
and then the second i get close to you
i'm just gonna immediately clinch up on
you
and then watching the experience this
way with the anticipation knowing that a
knockout was coming in such a short
amount of time
was like where is it where is this it's
gonna it's
gonna happen the more it becomes clear
that like
oh whatever maneuver is going to end
this is going to be something that
happens in like a split
second and isn't actually going to be
like impressive
snoop dogg's commentary was hysterical
that was the best part of the whole
fight to me hearing snoop talk on the
sidelines
part of me was like let's get snoop in
the ring and see what you can do
because at least it seems like he's had
some training at this too so when are
jake paul and logan paul going to fight
each other
that's a fight i would tune in live
exactly that's a fight i don't watch any
of their videos but that's a fight
i would absolutely tune in for i mean
it's got to happen at some point i mean
the way correction i've seen maybe five
logan paul videos i don't want to be
able we've seen
all of the best most well-received logan
but yeah no i mean that sounds like
something they would absolutely probably
do at some point once the each of them
probably has a bit more legitimacy
because it seems like jake paul actually
seems to care about pursuing this
i don't know if logan is is a dedicated
i can definitely see that like think of
how
much viewership how much promo they
could do for that like yeah that's gotta
happen
oh boy that was uh it was very amusing
that was thank you
thank you to all who asked me to cover
this i appreciate it thank you
all right guys well what is your
reaction to the fight that weird it's
old news by this point subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button last but not least let's do a
bradley bledsoe bradley at the time of
filming this i'm actually supposed to
call you in a little bit
i wanted to hire you to help edit some
stuff for us in regards to tv shows or
maybe movies
and bradley i know that lately you've
had kind of a difficult time
with the way your work has been i'm
sorry about that
last thing i want for you is to be going
through difficult times during the
holiday season i mean
a lot of us are but i especially don't
want that for you and your wife to be
going through a
challenging time but no on this end and
through many people who we become
friends with as well over at like our
you know discord patreon you are very
much loved love your enthusiasm love
your creativity i think you're a
wonderful
wonderful human being and i can't wait
to develop our relationship even
further and then let work drive it into
the ground
being like darn why did we agree to work
together
now he thinks we ship him on things
don't give him enough credit now he's
coming to me
but you will have earned it